petite mise en place briefing avec
l'équipe technique
salut hier j'étais en tournée et je
n'avais pas mon ordinateur avec moi et
je me suis aperçu d'un gros bug la vidéo
que j'avais programmé hier à 17 heures
n'avait pas la fin je sais pas comment
c'est possible
j'ai téléchargé depuis la version
entière de cette vidéo je vous la met en
lien dans la description de celle ci et
je vous mets également un lien vers la
chaîne de mikaël hirsch cette chaîne
drôle et intelligente que je vous
recommande aujourd'hui je voulais
revenir sur le discours que françois
hollande a eu hier par rapport à l'année
de donald trump c'est une tradition
française de féliciter l'arrivée du
nouveau président américain août la
nouvelle présidente américaine mais ça
n'a jamais été le cas pour l'instant
alors qu'on soit d'accord avec trump ou
pas qu'on soit d'accord avec ses idées
ou sont arrivés ou pas seul jean rien au
fait qu'ils soient là et ça ne change
rien au fait que ça bien me françois
hollande dans la galère surtout quand on
sait que l'elysée avait prévu un seul
discours hier à l'elysée n'avait écrit
prévu qu'un seul discours je laisse
deviner pour qui bref un petit peu en
rond avec les vidéos que j'ai faite la
semaine dernière par rapport au micro
expressions je vous propose une rapide
analyse du discours de françois hollande
dès le départ on voit bien que sa
manière de déglutir et de se positionner
et même de prendre son inspiration qui
n'est pas très à l'aise non il n'est pas
à l'aise là il préférait très très loin
d'ici
je pense également qu'il a été coaché
d'une manière générale les hommes
politiques sont coachés mais là
précisément parce qu'il sait qu'il peut
être le centre d'attention du monde
entier vis-à-vis de cette déclaration là
tout le monde va la regarder en tout cas
au moins une fois c'est sûr il ya une
vraie recherche de maîtrise du visage
durant tout ce discours ce qui explique
peut-être pourquoi les deux sourcils
sont légèrement verrouillé peut-être
pour empêcher des mouvements il fait
comme ça et contracte légèrement les
sourcils
autant vous dire qu'il aurait mieux fait
de contracter tout le reste parce que
durant toute la vidéo j'ai eu
l'impression de voir petit groupe de
rebond 10 et de partout il n'ya pas
d'ancrage il n'est pas à l'aise il
cherche un appui en permanence ce qui
explique que son bras gauche soit
toujours en contact avec le public quand
ces palettes de bras il cherche un appui
quelque part je sais même pas s'il est
resté dans la même position plus de
trois secondes d'affilée alors il ya
deux explications possibles soit ils
cherchent un ancrage dans le sol il
n'arrive pas à être sur ses appuis il
n'est pas à l'aise soit il a une envie
très pressante très très pressant je
vous laisse choisir le résultat des
votes aux états unis ne l'arrangent pas
salah gas même on le voit à plusieurs
endroits et que pincement des lèvres
avec la dilatation des narines
cette élection américaine ou une période
d'incertitude
il éprouve d'ailleurs du mépris ici qui
dit et et clarté on reconnaît la
symétrie au coin des lèvres et celui ci
est magnifique c'est le recul qu'il à ce
moment là c'est un signe typique du
mépris et on l'a également lorsqu'il
parle de donald trump président de la
mettre dans un beau donald trump durant
la campagne américaine campagne amérique
il ya un truc amusant c'est qu'il nous
donne également dans son discours un
pléonasme corporelle et son inverse
je laisse juste regarder cet extrait en
plein écran ou une période d'incertitude
de celtitude insultes itunes vous avez
pu voir ici que tout son corps fait oui
ça acquiesce vraiment ce qu'il est en
train de lire alors que plus loin quand
on voit ça les etats unis constituent un
partenaire bon ben là vous l'avez
clairement vu quand il aborde la notion
de partenaires gros n'ont pas très envie
françois tout tourne en fait autour
d'une vraie déception pour françois
hollande
on peut la voir ici parce que c'est pas
le plan qu'il avait projeté qu'il avait
prévu et c'est là je crois que se situe
tout l'interprétation de tout ce qu'on
vient de dire où l'on n'est pas du tout
centré sur les élections américaines il
est centré sur les prochaines élections
françaises d'une part avec la peur de ce
qui pourrait se passer en france
parce que là on est en train de
constater que quand les électeurs sont
dans l'isoloir
c'est là où ils ont vraiment le pouvoir
ils peuvent même mettre quelque chose
juste pour voir ce que ça fait en fait
de redistribuer le jeu différemment et
d'autre part il a constaté que les
français et c'est sûr il a constaté au
moins via les réseaux sociaux il ya des
communicants pour ça qu'ils lui en parle
que le peuple français étaient
globalement contre trump et même si on a
toutes les raisons de l'être est lui
aussi un petit effet de mode comme ça
durant 24 heures hier du coup en faisant
le discours tel qu'il l'a fait françois
hollande
il fait deux choses il joue une tour sur
son échiquier pour faire comprendre aux
français qu'il est de l'avis de la
majorité d'entre eux mais il sait aussi
manger un cavalier dans sa relation
internationale parce que qu'on le
veuille ou non
donald trump et président des états unis
enfin prend ses fonctions au mois de
janvier mais ça va être lui le nouveau
président du coup je suis pas sûr et
certain qu'ils quittent cet accueil
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
n'oubliez pas de laisser un like si vous
avez aimé ce concept de prendre une
vidéo récente un discours et de vous le
détailler
n'hésitez pas à vous exprimer dans les
commentaires mais je vous demanderai de
continuer à être respectueux dans les
échanges
j'ai beaucoup de chance mois vis-à-vis
de la communauté donc fait partie c'est
que j'ai une communauté coup les
bienveillantes
donc j'espère que d'aborder un sujet un
peu plus politique qu'un sujet comme ça
ça va pas changer la donne pour info je
suis en spectacle avec le toujours
fabien olicard vous mentalist qui est un
mélange de mentalisme et d'humour que
certains ont déjà les goûts hier sur
scène le 10 décembre à clayes-sous-bois
le 31 décembre pour lol dernière journée
de l'année
je serai à versailles à la voile factory
et en janvier les premières dates de
janvier ce sont les 6 et 7 novembre à
lille au spotlight
je vous mets un lien vers toutes les
dates de spectacles dans la description
de la vidéo si vous venez n'hésitez pas
à attendre à la fin du spectacle je
prends toujours du temps pour qu'on se
rencontre pour qu'on discute parce que
il n'y a pas qu'à vous que ça fait
plaisir un mois aussi n'oubliez pas de
vous abonner à la chaîne avant de partir
parce que mon blog c'est une vidéo par
jour pendant un an
janvier au 31 décembre c'est ça le défi
de cette année et on avance
tranquillement en avant ce rendez-vous
demain à 17h charge
palau